.
WE'LL TALK TO DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN VERONICA ESCOBAR
THAT REPRESENTS THE EL PASO AREA
IN A MOMENT BUT ED LAVANDERA IS
IN EL PASO WHERE THOUSANDS OF MY
GRANDS ARE CROSSING INTO THE
U.S. EACH DAY AND AUTHORITIES
ARE STRUGGLING WITH HOW TO
RESPOND.
>> Reporter: THE CITY OF EL
PASO, TEXAS IS EXPERIENCING A
MAJOR SURGE OF BORDER CROSSINGS
AS THE PROJECTED END OF A TRUMP
ERA COVID RESTRICTION DRAWS
CLOSER.
MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN BARRED FROM
ENTERING SINCE MARCH 2020 AND IN
VENT DAYS 2500 MIGRANTS A DAY
HAVE BEEN MOVING.
>> TITLE 42 IS ONLY GOING TO
MAKE THAT SITUATION WORSE WHERE
THEY HAVE MORE APPREHENSIONS SO
WE'LL SEE A LOT MORE RELEASES
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND WE'RE NOT
PREPARED FOR IT.
>> Reporter: THREE WEEKS AGO,
ACCORDING TO CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION, THE SEVEN-DAY
ROLLING AVERAGE WAS FEWER THAN
1700S OF MIGRANTS ARE COMING
NOT JUST FROM CENTRAL AND SOUTH
AMERICA BUT HAITI AND CUBA
ACCORDING TO U.S. IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS.
>> I'M HELPING THEM GET FOOT.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT POLITICS
BUT HUMANITY.
>> Reporter: SOME HAVE BEEN
CAMPING OUT ACROSS THE BORDER
INTO MEXICO RAISING CONCERNS
THEY WILL CROSS IN MASS IF TRUMP
ERA BORDER RESTRICTIONS IN ABOUT
A WEEK.
STILL OTHERS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
BOARDED ON BUSES TO BE PROCESSED
OR TURNED AROUND UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF TITLE 42.
>> WE'RE TALKING STEPS TO BE
ABLE TO MANAGE THE EXPIRATION OF
TITLE 42 AND PUT IN PLACE A
PROCESS THAT IS ORDERLY AND
HUMAN AND IN DOING SO WE CAN
PROTECT NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERNS.
>> Reporter: HOMELAND SECRETARY
ARRIVED IN EL PASO TODAY AND
SAYS HE'S MEETING WITH CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PROTECTION, LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND ORGANIZATIONS.
FOR NOW, THE IMMEDIATE PROBLEM
IS HOUSING AND MANAGING A LARGE
INFLUX OF MIGRANTS.
>> IF THE COURT CASES GET
RESOLVED AND THE COURTS ALLOW
TITLE 42 TO BE LIFTED, WE'RE
GOING TO SEE THOUSANDS OF
REFUGEES FOR WHOM THERE ISN'T
SHELTER.
>> Reporter: THE DIRECTOR OF A
LOCAL SHELTER SAYS BORDER PATROL
DROPPED A BUS LOAD OF MIGRANTS
AT HIS DOORSTEP AND HE'S WORRIED
HE'LL SOON HAVE TO TURN PEOPLE
AWAY.
>> WE'LL HAVE TO SAY NO, NOT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BUT SIMPLY
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE SPACE.
THE REALITY IS THERE IS TOO MANY
PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: JAKE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PROJECTING 9
TO 14,000 MIGRANTS A DAY COULD
BE ARRIVING AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IF TITLE 42 IS LIFTED
NEXT WEEK.
THAT'S ROUGHLY DOUBLE THE
NUMBERS WE'VE SEEN OF
APPREHENSIONS IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS.
THERE IS STILL A CHANCE THAT
TITLE 42 IS KEPT IN PLACE.
THERE ARE STILL COURT ALCOHOL
-- CHALLENGES PLAYING OUT.
WE SHOULD HAVE MORE INFORMATION
THIS WEEK.
>> ED LAVANDERA, THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ASKING
CONGRESS FOR $3 BILLION AS IT
PREPARES FOR THE END OF TITLE 42
BUT WILL CONGRESS GIVE HIM THAT
MONEY?
PHIL MATTINGLY IS BACK WITH US.
PHIL, WHAT IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
PLANNING TO DO.
>> JAKE, OFFICIALS ARE SEEING
MAY HAPPEN IN LESS THAN A WEEK.
THE REQUEST IS PART OF A BROADER
FUNDING REQUEST IN THE MIDDLE OF
CONGRESSIONAL NEGOTIATIONS TO
TRY AND ASSIST IN BORDER
MANAGEMENT FOR TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE, SURGING
PERSONNEL DOWN TO THE BORDER,
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN UNDERWAY.
ALL PART OF AN INTENIVE BEHIND
THE SCENES PROCESS OFFICIALS
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS FOR THIS
MINUTE.
ED MENTIONED THERE IS QUESTIONS
IN TERMS OF HOW THE COURTS WILL
END UP FOR ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS.
THEY AREN'T NECESSARILY PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE QUESTIONS.
>> HOW IS CONGRESS RESPONDING TO
THE REQUEST SO FAR FROM WHAT YOU
CAN TELL?
>> Reporter: THE COMPLICATION IS
REPUBLICANS SAID THEIR OVERALL
ASSESSMENT HOW THE WHITE HOUSE
HANDLED THE BORDER MADE THEM
RELUCTANT TO ENGAGE ON REQUESTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE HOWEVER,
IT'S CURRENTLY PART OF FUNDING
NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW WHEN YOU TALK TO WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIALS, THEY MADE CLEAR
THAT THE REPUBLICANS WANT
ANSWERS ON THE BOARDER, IF THEY
WANT SOLUTIONS ON THE BOARDER,
THEY'RE PUSHING FOR BIPARTISAN
IMMIGRATION REFORM AND NEED THIS
FUNDING AND THEY ARE AT LEAST
BASED ON OFFICIALS THAT I'VE
SPOKEN TO WILLING TO HAVE THAT
FIGHT IF REPUBLICANS VOTE
AGAINST THE FUNDING, THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING AT THE
BORDER, REPUBLICANS COULD BE THE
ONES STANDING IN WAY, JAKE.
>> PHIL MATTINGLY, THANKS.
LET'S BRING IN VERONICA ESCOBAR
THAT REPRESENTS EL PASO, TEXAS.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS FOR
JOINING US AND MERRY CHRISTMAS,
YOUR LOVELY BACKGROUND IS VERY
ENTICING.
WE'RE SEEING THESE IMAGES OF
CROWDS AT THE BORDER CROSSING
INTO THE U.S.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING AND HEARING
FROM CITIZENS IN YOUR DISTRICT?
>> JAKE, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME ON TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
I HAVE BEEN WARNING FOR A LONG
TIME NOW, ACTUALLY FOR YEARS
THAT THE SITUATION WOULD
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE AND BECOME
EVEN MORE UNSUSTAINABLE IF
CONGRESS DIDN'T ACT.
AND AS YOU KNOW, CONGRESS HASN'T
PASSED AN IMMIGRATION BILL SINCE
1996 AND BACK THEN, NEARLY 30
YEARS AGO, WHAT CONGRESS DID WAS
ESSENTIALLY LIMIT LEGAL
PATHWAYS.
AND CONGRESS AND ADMINISTRATION
HAVE CHOSEN TO ADDRESS
IMMIGRATION AS A BORDER ONLY
ISSUE.
DEALING WITH IMMIGRATION AS A
BORDER ISSUE IS PROBLEMS TODAY.
HERE IS WHAT I'M HEARING IN THE
COMMUNITY, AND JAKE, IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO SAY OUR
COMMUNITY AND A HAND FULL OF
COMMUNITIES HELD THIS BURDEN FOR
FAR TOO LONG AND WE NEED HELP.
I'M HEARING FROM AGENTS AND
FAMILIES HOW INCREDIBLY
STRESSFUL THIS SITUATION IS.
THE IMPACT, THE STRESS ON
FAMILIES, CHILDREN, WHO ARE
SUPPORTING OUR FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL, OUR
PERSONNEL ARE MISSING BIRTHDAYS,
HOLIDAYS, ET CETERA.
I'M HEARING FROM THE NGOs HOW
OVER STRESSED THEY ARE, OVER
CAPACITY.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING THE
BEST THEY CAN TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT BUT THEY NEED THE
RESOURCES SO THAT WE AREN'T
DIPPING INTO LOCAL FUNDS.
I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY'RE THE FIRST ADMINISTRATION
FULLY REIMBURING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES LIKE MY OWN FOR
EXPENSES BUT WE NEED MORE THAN
MONEY.
WE NEED LEGISLATION THAT I'VE
PROVIDED TO THE ADMINISTRATIONA
>> EL PASO DOESN'T HAVE THE
ROOM.
IN EL PASO, BORDER ENCOUNTERS
WERE MONTH LAST YEAR AND
A MAKESHIFT CAMP IN A PARKING
GARAGE AS LOCAL SHELTERS WERE
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED AND THAT
GROUP WAS LATER KICKED OUT OF
THE GARAGE.
WOULD YOU CALL WHAT IS HAPPENING
NOW IN EL PASO A CRISIS BECAUSE
IT LOOKS LIKE ONE FROM WHERE I'M
SITTING.
>> YEAH, IT'S ABSOLUTELY A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE SLEEPING ON
THE STREETS, THAT IS AN
UNACCEPTABLE SITUATION, FOR
THEM, FOR THE COMMUNITY AND
THERE IS A SOLUTION TO THIS.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB AS A COMMUNITY OF
ESSENTIALLY HELPING MOVE FOLKS
BETWEEN WHAT BORDER PATROL IS
DOING AND WHAT THE COUNTY OF EL
PASO IS DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
MIGRANTS ARE GETTING TO THEIR
FINAL DESTINATION BECAUSE AS YOU
KNOW, JAKE, EL PASO ISN'T THEIR
DESTINATION.
THEY ARE REUNITING WITH FAMILY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS THEY AWAIT
THEIR ASYLUM HEARING.
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THE HELP AND
SUPPORT IS IN THE EMERGENCY
SHELTER AREA.
MOST OF THESE FOLKS HAVE
PURCHASED EITHER AIRLINE TICKETS
ONCE THEY'VE GOTTEN HERE OR GRAY
HOUND BUS TICKETS BUT SOMETIMES
THEY CAN'T GET A TICKET OUT THE
SAME DAY AND, YOU KNOW, THEY'LL
HAVE TO WAIT ONE DAY OR TWO DAYS
AND THEY NEED A PLACE TO SLEEP,
A PLACE TO STAY.
AND OUR NGOs ARE BEYOND
CAPACITY.
I HAD A CONVERSATION LATE LAST
NIGHT WITH ROSA, OUR
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRWOMAN AND I
SEE THE BUS AS AN OPPORTUNITY,
YOU KNOW, YOUR REPORTER JUST
TALKED ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT
FUNDING THAT WE'RE HOPING TO GET
DONE FOR THE NEXT 12 MONTHS AND
THAT WE'RE HOPING TO PASS FOR
CHRISTMAS EVE.
I'M HOPING THAT THAT BUS AND
I'VE ADVOCATED FOR AND WROTE A
LETTER AND SPOKE TO ROSA TO THE
CHAIRWOMAN, WE ALSO NEED IN
ADDITION TO ROBUST FUNDING
EVERYTHING LAID OUT BY YOUR
REPORTER, WE ALSO NEED FEDERALLY
RUN EMERGENCY SHELTERS SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE FOLKS SLEEPING ON
THE STREET AND SO MY HOPE IS
THAT REPUBLICANS WILL SEE WHAT
IS HAPPENING, WILL UNDERSTAND
THAT WE NEED THE RESOURCES TO
RESPOND IMMEDIATELY TO THIS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS BUT OVER THE
LONG TERM, JAKE, CONGRESS HAS
KICKED THE CAN FOR TOO LONG.
THERE IS A WAY TO ADDRESS THIS